if you live in America and you pay taxes
you want to pay attention to this video
look everybody in America no Social
Security is broken everybody knows it it
doesn't matter if you're 20 years old or
70 years old everyone knows it's broken
however most people don't know why today
in this video I'm going to break down
with you going back to when Social
Security benefits first got started what
the actual age was supposed to be
compared to the life expectancy at the
time and how the numbers gone up in
Alaska at least five sources of
retirement that people rely on and how
some things have changed in the last few
years so let's get right into it the
first thing we're gonna look at is life
expectancy at the time where Social
Security was introduced versus actual
age of retirement for 100% benefits
here's what it looks like
1935 FDR introduces Social Security
right age of retirement 400% benefits
was 65 but the life expectancy for the
average male in America was 59 point
nine years which means barely 60 which
means five point one years short of 65
which means the average male is never
going to see these benefits now the
average female was sixty three point
nine which is still a shortage of one
point one years at a time where the
population America 127 million now this
continues if you go through it the 1945
still 65 but the life expectancy goes up
to sixty three point six which is still
short average female life expectancy was
67 point nine which means now the
average female yes to enjoyed the
benefits for about two point nine years
population was 139 right now when you
continue in 1955 the age of retirement
hundred percent benefits goes to 66 then
a male life expectancy goes up now
they're seeing benefits of it for about
point seven years and the average female
life expectancy 72 point eight they get
to lay of six point eight years enjoying
retirement benefits from Social Security
and then as you go down and bump down a
little bit and then it came back up well
today at around 2016 the average life
expectancy for male is seventy six point
two which means they get nine point two
years of benefits and the average
females life expectancy is eighty-one
point one which they get fourteen point
one years of benefit
so now you look at this and you say Pat
what's the big deal I don't understand
it
here's the big deal the program was
initially created for those that in case
you live too long let us help you out
with some payments here because you got
an e you need some payment plan from the
government to support you
it wasn't a source of retirement it was
in case you out lived which means if we
take the same exact formula of how it
was started in 1935 and look at it for
today this is when the benefits need to
start today if we go exactly on how FDR
and his administration introduced Social
Security to the American people so the
average life expectancy today in 2019
for female is eighty one point four and
for a male is seventy six point three
six okay so remember over here where
female was one point one year less than
what the life expectancy was and for
male was five point one years less than
what the life expectancy was that means
the average benefit for FEMA would start
at eighty two and a half and the average
benefit for male would start at eighty
one point four six you take the average
of the two eighty two years if Social
Security today the benefits was set up
the same exact way that it was in 1935
benefits will need to start at 82 years
old today 82 years old can you imagine
if somebody on the campaign trail right
now for presidential election where
everybody's saying Medicare for all this
for all I want to be able to eliminate
school loans I want to be able to let me
at this imagine somebody on campaign
trail says I think America is broke yeah
I think America doesn't have any money
I think we think America is rich but man
America is and a lot of debt I think we
need to really consider raising the
Social Security benefits to 82 years old
similar to how was when it was first
introduced by FDR what do you think
would happen to that candidate oh
they're off there's no way in the world
I mean anyone's gonna vote for that
person because people want that benefits
and a lot of this is the politicians to
blame because they keep giving more free
things more free things and people kept
voting for it and now America is paying
a price for now let's look at the dollar
amount let's look at the Daruma 1937
there was a total number of 53,000
beneficiaries
receiving benefits now I keep this on
mine it's 53,000 on roughly 130 million
people living in America at that time
their total benefits that America had to
pay per year was roughly one point two
seven eight million dollars not a
billion dollars million dollars it was
an average of $24 of payments per
beneficiary per your not per month let
me say this again $24 per year in 1937
to only 53,000 people which in today's
dollars that to $24 is really four
hundred and thirty dollars if you do the
inflation math in it so what does that
really mean by the way the four thirty a
year compared to today is sixteen
thousand to fifty eight per EUR it went
from being a supplemental hey I know
America is going through tough times
it's great depressions challenging times
here's an additional four hundred thirty
dollars to help you not retire because
it's only twenty four dollars per year
in today's almost 4:30 here's some money
to help you out with here's some money
to help you out with over the years
politicians turn it into a retirement
plan so look what happens next in
nineteen forty now we have two hundred
twenty two thousand people receiving the
benefits thirty-five million dollar cost
and it went one hundred fifty seven
dollars per year which is in today's
dollars two thousand eight seventeen
then we went to three point five million
it was about nine hundred sixty one
million per year two hundred seventy six
dollars per payment which is around
three thousand today's dollars every one
fourteen point nine million we can go
all the way up if you want the PDF we'll
have the PDF for you at the end so stick
around for that part but today 63
million people benefit from this sixty
three million people are taking Social
Security today out of three hundred and
thirty million people in America it's
costing us one trillion twenty two
dollars per year one point twenty two
trillion dollars per year that is 25
percent of our annual expenses u.s.
expenses is all due to Social Security
25 percent in Social Security
sixteen thousand to fifty eight on
average is what we're experiencing today
with Social Security so you look at this
math you and say wait a minute Pat is
that real these are the numbers go look
at and we get
we'll put all the links below they can
go look through for you to find out do
your own research matter of fact now
let's go through some of the dollars on
this side you look at this and you say
so how does it work today because some
people take benefits at 62 is it really
62 is it 65 67 what is a real age if you
take social security at 62 you get 70%
of benefits if you take it at 65 its
eighty six point seven percent if you
take it at sixty seven it's a hundred
percent now this is for folks who are
born after 1963 1960 the numbers favored
them a little bit more post 1960 you're
looking at them numbers you're looking
at so now let's get into remember how I
said to you the real cost is 25 percent
of America's expenses per year this is
America if it was a business I'm gonna
keep reminding for everybody realized
the basic math of this we bring in three
point three trillion dollars per year
that's income that's revenues coming in
right but America spends four point one
trillion dollars per year which is a
loss of eight hundred billion dollars
per year and because of that here's our
total unfunded liabilities u.s. is total
unfunded liabilities which means we have
not paid for this we're gonna be paying
for this what's the total amount if you
go on u.s. dethklok website you can see
the link we normally share this debt
clock it tells you to the second where
we are today and when I did it it's
partly gonna be hard when you do it when
I did it Social Security unpaid
commitment is twenty trillion dollars
sixty billion 20 trillion sixty billion
dollars that we haven't yet paid out
that we gotta pay out and last year
alone was a trillion dollars for
unfunded liabilities with Medicare is
roughly thirty one trillion dollars but
total unfunded liabilities of America
you ready
hundred and twenty six billion through
48 six eighteen 123 when we did it just
now what is it when you looked at it
comment below I'm curious to see how
quickly it went up right one hundred and
twenty six trillion dollars and people
say America's rich America is the
richest country in the world based on
what I know a lot of people that I go
into their house they got exotic cars
that got you know Bugattis they got
Rolls Royce because $300,000 watches
forty six thousand dollars suits
oh my gosh the sky is so rich he lives
in a twenty million dollar house and and
I look at their finances they're in debt
so much money they have no idea what the
hell to do just because these guys make
a lot of money per year doesn't make
them rich they spend more than they make
they are so broke you have no idea
they're about to lose it all it's a
glasshouse story and that's exactly
what's going on with America why because
politicians kept selling kept selling
kept selling and we kept voting we kept
voting we kept voting we kept voting yes
more free yes more free now here's
what's going on smaller countries who
don't have this kind of liabilities are
richer than America's nobody talks about
Norway Kai's from Norway we were talking
about this the other day
Norway is richer than America is if you
go simply based on basic needs analysis
of what a financial adviser at these big
firms do when you look at their income
assets versus their liabilities that
they have so now Pat I I don't really
get it what are you saying are you
saying we said you're suggesting raising
that 282 I mean it's one of the things
you gotta do are you saying we lowered
amount of payments it's another thing we
got to do so so what is really the
solution let me bring you back it's not
that easy to say it's black and white
and here's what we got to do there's
five ways we rely on retirement you and
I our family our parents our
grandparents rely on retirement and it's
kind of adjusted over the years okay so
let's go through some of them one of
them is based on your investments and
savings if you do a good job saving
money investing money guess what when
you get to a certain age you're not
relying on anybody I'm taking a
retirement because you've done a good
job saving money instead of doing a
barbecue every weekend with your friends
and having cases of beer and all this
stuff you know what you did you set that
money aside instead of going to Europe
every year maybe you went to another
place knew your cost you a third of the
writter vacation instead of living in
their house you wanted to live in maybe
about a smaller house and set aside and
did some investments so investments and
savings is one the other one is family
for many years
grandparents live with kids check hey
who's gonna live here well grandma's got
a room upstairs oh she's got her room
over there you know her grandparents are
living over here they help raise the
kids so we don't have to have a cost for
a nanny and we don't have to find a
place for them to live so you don't have
a renter you don't have this to help
with food and they kind of help with
this
kind of
down we're not doing that anymore in
America right
you know grandparents have to live by
themselves and kids are kind of my mom
I've got my own life to live in that's
the culture we have in America right so
family all that so that's another cost
then you have company 401 KS right you
rely on a company to take care of an
employee I work for your company you
take care of me matter of fact there
used to be a time when the whole debate
took place with Ford and their employees
when there was a strike
Ford employees came for a pension plan
and said if we give you a certain amount
of our lives and we work for you we want
to be able to take be taking cover in
return and Ford finally with the union
they negotiate said yes but in 1980 we
had 112 thousand pension plans in
America today we only have 24,000
pension plans in America so companies
are being pushed around with taxes where
they're like listen I can't afford to do
pension I'll just do 401k right just
before 1k now the benefit of 401ks if
the company goes belly flop you can take
your 401k to another company but
sometimes the pension is linked to the
company stocks and if the company goes
belly flop so does your pension so it's
not really protected so there's a lot of
that going on with company then you have
the government should the government
take care of us I mean it's cost them
you know 25 percent of their expenses
per year to fund Social Security should
we all rely on the company or should we
rely on you know us continuing working
right because a lot of people nowadays
are like well you gotta retire early
you got to retire early who the hell
came up with this whole thing about
retiring early anyways yeah you know how
many people when they retired they feel
like they're getting closer to death and
psychologically messes with them I don't
even want to have an age determined why
do you make me think 65 the age or 67 th
don't give me an age let me continue
transitioning out right my dad is 77
1942 77 years old he's still working not
because he has to he's watching dad what
are you doing here's his answer to me he
says what do you want me to do and so
won't you come move to Dallas he says
man every time I make something I feel
good about it I got to make something to
feel like I'm still giving value why do
you want me to retire my dad gets upset
with me when I'm on the selfish side as
a son I want him to be right next to my
kids so grandkids can get some value
from there
and he says just level with me man let
me work please let me work the moment I
stopped working I died this is my dad
telling me this I'm not 77 years I'm 40
so we're looking at this whole
retirement thing and in a way that the
companies are partially to blame the
government's partially to blame
we are partially to blame because we
voted and we cannot allow others to
adjuster what we think you know some of
the family rituals and cultures is also
something that we got to look at because
family you got also do your apartment
your kids want to support you it's not a
one-dimensional answer it's a lot of
different things all I'm saying to you
I'm gonna speak to you you are listening
to me forget about if somebody's
watching this and their Andrew yank fans
insane the hell with you yanking
thousand dollars a month for everybody
we are the richest we can afford to pay
1.5 trillion
no problem that's your views you know I
can't believe you said this Bernie we
got to write off all the college debt
that government 1.6 trillion dollars we
got you know Elizabeth Warren this or we
gotta go
you know Trump we need more military
you're saying this all I'm saying to you
is the following
I'm speaking to you the individual I'm
not talking politics I'm speaking to the
individual okay you you and I are
speaking nobody else hear me out let me
just give my points here okay for me
this is my recommendation to you don't
let anybody put a retirement age in your
head
don't put it don't even let that word
linger and come into your head use the
word transition for you
transition I'm not gonna retire I don't
want to believe I'm gonna retire okay
some of us like my dad are gonna work 40
hours we got 77 years so because you
want you there's a lot of people that
worked at a very very young because they
want to keep building in your mind maybe
you go from working 40 hours to 20 hours
to 10 hours but you're transitioning
into still doing something because you
got to be able to earn your an income
you cannot rely on the government or
your 401k to take you cannot do that
this is going to blow up eventually it's
just a time bomb this is not going to
and by the way this is not going like
this this is going like this you're
gonna pay a price for this a lot of
people are worried about climate change
I get climate change I fine I understand
them maybe we'll do video on it this is
this is gonna affect everybody living in
America
everybody living in America and that's
when all of us on the marquee goes like
this a sudden crash like this because
this is real dollars this is not
hypothetical without something would
seem this is pure proof that we know
this was going to be taking place if
you're watching me
number one get a little bit more serious
about your money understand the rules of
money and how it works
understand the game the doubles game
understand it get clear on that part
number two get the skill set constantly
fine-tune your skill set so your skill
set can advance for years and you're
always adapting with how automation a
everything is moving keep adapting
you're maybe 60 years old watching this
if your skill set was good for the 80s
and 90s we're not good today you better
start finding a skill set that's gonna
be good for 2025 not 2020 2025 like what
what do you need to start looking for
where you can find a way to you can't
rely on taxi and uber if you're 61 years
old saying that pays me an additional
$2,000 a month because that's gonna be
going away you have to start thinking
about those adjustments yourself your
investments stop just wasting all this
money start being a little bit more
frugal with your money start saving your
money investing your money start getting
very serious about it don't just wing it
if your company offers a 400 401 k plan
or benefits plan and they match start
putting all the money in there if
they're matching not all your money but
whatever them if they're if they're
matching a hundred percent up to five
percent or a hundred percent up to four
percent of fifty percent
nothing's gonna give you better returns
than that actually go sit with your
person and ask them what are the funds
for a 401 k start getting serious about
your money because if you rely on this
to take care of you and this to take
care of you times have changed it is on
you you and you that's the only way we
can be a little bit more free without
being affected by this without being
affected by this
you are gonna be affected by this but
not as much if you're able to control
yourself that's what I would do if I
were you and that's the history of
Social Security I want to hear your
thoughts comment below I'm not assuming
you gonna agree with me or disagree with
me if you go out there and do your own
due diligence to prove me wrong I love
that go do your own research to get
clear about it but these are my thoughts
on Social Security a couple videos I
want you to watch one is 20 rolls of
money I did this
a couple years ago it's got a few
million views it's 20 rules of money if
you haven't watched it go watch this
video the other video I want you to
watch it has to do with this is the
minimum wage debate okay if you haven't
watched a minimum wage debate the video
that I make about argument of minimum
wage versus complete different a number
I bring up go watch this video so 20
rules of money minimum wage whichever
video attracts to you and wherever
you're at go watch those videos and if
you haven't subscribe to this channel
please do so take everybody bye-bye